Arizona it's home to some of the
harshest immigration laws in the country
and more than 300,000 undocumented
immigrants in the capital Phoenix
activists spent the past two decades
battling Sheriff Joe Arpaio notorious
for racial profiling late-night raids
and his tent city outdoor prison Arpaio
was voted out last year but his friend
President Trump is delivering on the
promise to crack down hard on immigrants
we came to Phoenix to see how families
are living under the constant threat of
arrest
[Music]
in his first week of office Trump issued
executive orders to aggressively find
and remove the undocumented now Isis
even deporting those who've been
following the law by regularly checking
in with authorities that's what happened
to Guadalupe Garcia de Deus one of the
first to be deported under Trump her
husband asked not to be named in fear of
ice yeah so this is my pointing day we
are following breaking news here we're
in Arizona this mother of two has just
been deported back to her native Mexico
Guadalupe story made national headlines
and she became a symbol of those caught
in the Trump administration's widening
deportation net they decide to erase her
saying that time she's a priority she's
a priority and now under trans
administration when she was never seen
as a priority before in 2008 what a Lupe
was arrested in a workplace raid led by
Arpaio and convicted of using a fake
social security number she'd been
routinely reporting to ice for years but
this past February things went
differently I so ray our lawyer come up
without her I was like oh god this is
not good that's when we took action and
stopped the band
[Music]
my kids cry when they soar I mean I
didn't do it because I wanted them to
say strong - you know so somebody has to
to be the strong one for people who read
the headlines you know they might read
that a 36 year old undocumented woman
with a criminal record was deported back
to Mexico what do you want people to
know about guadeloupean about the woman
that she is here only wrongdoing is just
being being poor you know she has made
about social numbers she was her name
just for work just to pray for her for
her for her kids you know while the Lupe
was brought to Arizona as a teen she's
the mother of two american-born kids but
now she's alone back in Mexico a country
she hardly knows so you're gonna give
her a call no guesses how are you
feeling now and how's life in Mexico
been this past month so poco de si pero
cuando Ella ganas de Mer okay nada
Solyndra what do you want people who are
watching this story to know what do you
want to tell them ellos se que no se
ponen princess cake a salad Ella what's
life been like for you guys since quite
a Lopez been deported she's missing so
you had the boy inside of you you know
like something's missing in your life my
that is 14 right in
her body's changing so she's had the
stage which she needs her mom to talk
about women stuff she needs her mom I
mean my they need him they need more
than anything anybody seeing what
happened to Guadalupe she went in she
was trying to be law-abiding and checked
herself into it--and got deported what
do you say to people in her position who
are thinking about going to ice for the
regular check-ins if I wasn't a
situation I wouldn't go personally why
because you cannot trust him my wife
should be an example like two people to
see what ice is gonna do to your family
in fact soon after we arrived in Arizona
the migrant justice group went they
called a press conference another one of
its members had been detained during an
ice checkin aqui estamos con la familia
de Oscar DeLeon upon DeLeon pardoned
tatra familia que ma soeur separado por
las policías de presidente officer came
out and told us that he wanted to say
goodbye to us and I hate to give me his
stuff so we went in and said goodbye
para mezzago muy difícil de entender que
lo a ganar estado mer mondo pour % r SE
como siempre tenia que hacer lo Juan had
been caught years ago using a fake
social security number and was following
the law by regularly checking in with
ice under Obama people like Juan could
stay in the country so long as they did
that but now under Trump these ice
visits are turning tragic from the
perspective of a lot of community
members I mean what incentive do they
have then to go to ice anymore and do a
regular check-in well we're seeing that
people that are trained themselves into
ice are getting deported
so you know if you're going to turn
yourselves into ice you're more than
likely to get deported it's just a
policy of mass deportation is
like we've never seen you know under
Obama we saw 30 million people it looks
like this president's aim is to get 8
million people and a million people as
everybody and that means organizers are
working overtime and anticipation of
more arrests we do the our attorneys for
the children in case you do get detained
that someone else can take care of them
while you're detain or if you do get
deported that they take them down to you
it sounds like you guys are preparing
this community for the worst case
scenario these days cuentas know your
rights trainings are packed
[Music]
for a long period of time almost half of
the deportations in the country were
coming from Arizona and so no one better
than us is prepared for what's to come
and so for us it's nothing new but it's
definitely something that's now at a
larger scale and it's been before
[Music]
we are going to get the bad ones out the
criminals and the drug deals and gangs
and gang members and cartel leaders but
Trump is going after more than just that
under his administration ice is now
using expedited removal to deport people
without a hearing or a judge's approval
and that's left this community on edge
wondering who among them is next
hey everyone it's Deena make sure you
watch part 2 of our series where we take
a look at detention what life is like
for those inside and what their families
were left behind how to deal with